this is convex influences and it's joint
work with an india day and raccoon radio
so the super high level this talks about
an emerging analogy
between monotone boolean functions on
the n-dimensional hypercube and
symmetric convex sets over gaussian
space
so just to remind everyone
the n dimensional hypercube is just a
collection of zero one strings of length
n and a function is said to be monotone
if flipping an input bit from zero to
one cannot cause the value of the
function to decrease
and we say that a set in rn is symmetric
if it's symmetric about the origin
or more concretely if a point x is in
the set then the point
minus x obtained by reflecting through
the origin
or flipping the sign of each of x's
coordinates is also in the set
and over the past few years many
structural
and algorithmic parallels have been
discovered between these two between
these two settings and this work in
particular explores a new notion of
influence for some macro convex sets
so i'm going to first start by sort of
briefly very briefly
describing some of the background and
some of these
parallels that people have discovered
between these two settings after which
um i'll spend some time talking about a
specific point of correspondence between
monotone boolean functions and symmetric
convex sets
and
this point of correspondence is actually
what led us to this new notion of
influence
so monotone boolean functions are very
natural class and have been extensively
studied and in combinatorics and boolean
function analysis and learning theory
and property testing in particular a lot
of a lot is known about their analytic
structure
low degree concentration about
learnability under the uniform
distribution and so on and so forth
but a lot of these these themes have
also been studied for symmetric convex
sets um
in
in
over gaussian space of course you sort
of replace the uniform distribution with
the gaussian distribution and you
replace the fourier transform with the
hermit transform but despite this a lot
of the results are still there's a
there's a very clear
correspondence between um the results
for monotone boolean functions and um
the analogous results for symmetric
convex sets of a gaussian space
and
one sort of
point of correspondence which makes this
analogy very clear in my opinion is um
is that of correlation inequalities and
this is sort of what led us to this work
as i just mentioned
so
um the hardest clickman inequality a
include informally says that any two
monotone boolean functions
on the n-dimensional hypercube are
non-negatively correlated um with
respect to the uniform distribution and
this is sort of a well-known well
studied
inequality which has lots of
applications in combinatorics and
statistical physics it's also um it's
also been known for a while it was
discovered in 1966
and its proof is
is a is a five or six line long
inductive argument so it's not too
difficult
on the other hand
in the setting of symmetric convex
that's the gaussian space the analogous
statement
is
is simply the fact that
any two
symmetric convex sets are non-negatively
correlated with respect to the standard
gaussian distribution
but this inequality um despite looking
very
similar to the the harris lightman
inequality was open for over 40 years
and it was only approved in 2014.
another way of stating um this
inequality which is
which is proved by thomas ryan and is is
called roy's inequality is as follows it
says that
the gaussian measure of the intersection
of two symmetric convex sets is at least
the product of the
gaussian measures of the sets themselves
so hopefully this the sort of
you know
maybe you're not not convinced that
there's a very concrete analogy between
these two settings but these two
statements are very similar
um
one thing to note about but these
statements is that they are qualitative
statements
um
or in other words what they say is that
all they say is that this the
correlation between any two functions
belonging to a certain family with
respect to some distribution is
non-negative
and the natural thing to hope for is
a robust version of this statement
or in other words a can we get a better
lower bound
on this correlation quantity and ideally
we'd want to do this in terms of some
property of the functions that we're
looking at
and when you think about the the
hashclickman inequality um it's it's
easy to check that
um
you have equality in the harris lightman
inequality
when the functions f and g depend on
disjoint sets of of coordinates
and
and so it's natural to hope for a lower
about in terms of how much
um the functions depend simultaneously
on the same s on a particular
coordinate um and this this
notion of dependence on a particular
coordinate is uh is actually a very well
studied quantity in boolean function
analysis and it's called the influence
of of a coordinate on the boolean
function
more formally if you've got a if you've
got a boolean function f
um
on the n-dimensional hypercube
you can define the influence of any of
its coordinates as follows um it's
inflow the influence of a coordinate on
on the function f is the probability
that when you choose a point uniformly
at random from the boolean hypercube the
value of the function at that point
is
is different from the value of the
function at the point obtained
by flipping
the ith coordinate or the ith bet of the
original point
and this is a very well studied quantity
and there's been a long line of very
interesting very
very very cool work built around this
whole notion of influence
returning to correlation inequalities um
telegramed
in 1996
asked this very exact question um
um namely that is it possible namely
whether it's possible to get
a
quantitative version of the hardest
clipman inequality
where the lower bound is you know some
function of these influences
and tolerance obtained such a bound in
1996
where
he showed that the correlation between
any two monotone boolean functions is
lower bounded by this function
psi
of the sum of the products of the
influences intelligence inequality has
found many applications in additive
combinatorics and boolean function
analysis and and elsewhere
so the story so far looks um looks looks
something like this you've got the
hardest lightning inequality which is
um
a qualitative correlation inequality and
you've got an analogous statement for
symmetric convex sets in the form of
rounds inequality
and then tolerance comes along and
robustifies the highest lightman
inequality to get this expression
um to get this this really cool
inequality which lower bounds the
correlation between two monotone boolean
functions in terms of the influences of
the two functions
and it's natural to hope for an
analogous statement
in the setting of symmetric convex set
silver gaussian space
and
this is precisely
what we and what we obtained in some
previous work
last year we showed that the correlation
between
two symmetric convex sets under the
gaussian distribution can be lower
bounded by this function
phi
of the sum of the products of the degree
two hermite coefficients
of of the two sets
so these functions fee and c
they're they're off by a logarithmic
factor but that doesn't matter too much
um
what what what's really
um crucial for the purposes of this talk
is that um
it looks like you know pattern matching
these these degree to hermit
coefficients sort of
seem analogous to influences
and motivated by this this analogy we
define
the convex influence
um
along a coordinate direction as the
negated degree to hermit coefficient
along that direction if you don't know
what the hermit coefficients are if you
don't know the immediate spectrum is
that's totally fine
it'll all disappear in a second and
there'll be a clean and crisp definition
of convex influence
but
before before i show you the definition
of convex influence
one thing to note is that
in gaussian space there's no canonical
direction so
it it's reasonable to hope for a
definition
of influence along any any direction and
so
given a symmetric convex set you can
define the influence of a direction on
that set as as this quantity
which is the expectation of the
indicator function
of
the
the convex set
times the negated
degree to hermit coefficient hermet
polynomial evaluated at um evaluated
along that direction
and um
this is uh it sort of looks like a
weird arbitrary technical quantity but
there's a there's a significantly more
intuitive way of um of thinking about
these influences
as
as follows so
given
a symmetric convex set k
um
let's say we are interested in the
influence along the first coordinate
direction e1
um so this is just e1 is just the basis
vector which has
one in the first entry and zeros
everywhere else
and you can sort of define this diagonal
matrix where you're sort of scaling um
your convex body
by
um
a factor of one plus delta in the first
direction and leaving all the other
coordinate directions unchanged
and
we're just going to denote this matrix m
sub delta
and it turns out by um
not to not not too hard calculation that
the influence of
e1 on on the convex set when the
symmetric convex set key is um
essentially capturing how much uh how
quickly
the gaussian measure of the set k
changes on their
dilations
when he dilated um along the first
coordinate axis
and this the sort of
characterization of convex influence in
terms of dilations is analogous to the
russo-margulis lemma for boolean
functions for those who know what that
is so at a very high level the the russo
margulis lemma
tells you how quickly um how the bias
or uh the volume of monotone boolean
function changes
as as you're sort of
varying the underlying measure um
so
as you're sort of changing the bias of
the
underlying measure on the
boolean hypercube
or in terms of pictures um
what the influence of the first
direction on a symmetric convex set
k
is is um
the
limit of
the change
in
the gaussian measure of this
new new set m sub delta k
and the original set k
divided by delta as you send delta to
zero so it's sort of the rate of change
of um
the gaussian measure as you sort of
dilate
um along the
first coordinate direction
up to some scaling factor because
getting factor of one over root two
but it's reasonable to to say you know
what what what happens if you sort of
not just dilating along
the just the
a particular direction but if you're
dilating the whole body
and this sort of motivates the the
notion of total convex influence
so
if you've got a symmetric convex set k
you can define the total convex
influences the rate of change of
volume of the set as you dilate it um
long
as you dilated sort of uniformly along
all along all directions
and it's easy to check that
the total convex influences
the total convex influence is nothing
but the sum of the
the
n-coordinate influences
and if you if you write down the
analytic expression it's it's easy to
see that
this quantity is um independent of
your choice of basis or in other words
the total convex influence is
rotationally invariant as long as you
pick any orthonormal basis it it remains
unchanged
again in terms of pictures um the total
convex influence is sort of the
the limit of this this is the gaussian
volume of this
light pink
purple region um
divided by sort of this this
dilation factor delta up to up to a
constant of 1 over 2.
and you might ask whether you know
is this even sort of a reasonable notion
of influence just as a sanity check
perhaps the the first thing you you'd
want to know is um whether the convex
influence is non-negative what are the
possible values it can take
and if you think about the
analogous notion of influence over the
boolean hypercube um
the influence of a variable on a boolean
function is always between zero and one
because it's simply a probability yeah
and so um it's natural to ask if this is
true for for convex influences right
and if you think about this
um coordinate bi-coordinate or this
this dilation definition of um
dilation characterization of conex
influence it's not immediately clear why
um
why the gaussian measure of this
dilate along
a certain direction is
more is bigger than the gaussian measure
of the original set
and
as you can see from this image when you
sort of dilate along the first
coordinate direction the new set m sub
delta k
doesn't necessarily contain the original
stat so it's not not exactly clear why
um
its gaussian measure would be increasing
also
in case it wasn't clear
if you could show that the gaussian
measure increases along dilations then
it would follow that the influence is
not negative as it's as as the numerator
and this fraction is always going to be
greater than equal to zero
but fortunately or surprisingly it turns
out that these convex influences are
indeed non-negative um
and this sort of
uses the fact that
if you have a symmetric convex set k
n minus one dimensional gaussian measure
of its cross sections is log concave
in particular you can sort of express
the
gaussian measure of the dilate in terms
of um
an integral which sort of uses
the fact that the gaussian that the body
is symmetric
um
and sort of low concavity implies that
this n minus one dimensional measure is
unimodal about the origin which
gives us the
desired relationship
um
or which shows that
the influence is non-negative
awesome so this tells us that the convex
influence is negative
and
the natural next natural follow-up
question perhaps is um
what happens if the convex influences is
precisely zero so in the boolean setting
if the influence of a particular
coordinate on a function is zero then
the function is independent of that
coordinate flipping the
value
of that coordinate never changes the
value of the function
and something similar holds for convex
influences um
in particular if the influence of a
partic of a certain direction is zero
then
the symmetric convex body k is
essentially a cylinder along that
direction up to up to a set of measure
zero or in other words it's sort of an n
minus one dimensional convex body which
is just sort of a cylinder or or just
like translated along that direction
and so this seems to check out as well
um
so so far it seems like you know the
convex influence is not negative and
it sort of behaves the way you would
want it to
um when when it's when it's precisely
zero
um
it might
another reasonable
hope would be to to sort of
um have analogs of
of um
you know some well-known standard
boolean functions and and sort of see
whether the convex influence of you know
these analogous
um symmetric convex sets is sort of
similar to the the boolean function the
influence of those boolean functions
so
uh perhaps one of the simplest boolean
functions are are dictator shapes which
are just the projection functions
so the dictatorship of the first
coordinate simply takes in n bits and
outputs the first bit
and it's easy to see that if you're
if if you're
the first coordinate then you have
influence 1 on this function
but if you're any other coordinate then
the influence is zero
and it turns out that the
analogous symmetric convex body is um
simply a slab that's oriented
along the first direction along the
first coordinate direction
so
k is simply the set of points
for which
the first coordinate has
absolute value some constant and it's
sort of independent of all the other n
coordinates
and the convex influence sort of behaves
the way you would expect it to and it's
zero for all these other coordinates
another
fundamental boolean function is the
majority function which takes in n bits
and outputs one if at least half the
bits are one
and um the influence of each coordinate
of the majority function is is one over
root n
and
it turns out that the symmetric convex
set which is analogous to the majority
function is
is the
the ball of uh gaussian volume half so
the majority function is sort of
capturing the top half of the boolean
hypercube and this this ball of gaussian
volume half is sort of capturing the
inner half of gaussian space
and again a calculation shows that the
influences
each of any direction for this ball
which is due to symmetry is is is on the
is
one over root n up to constant factors
and finally another sort of
well-known famous boolean function is
there is the tribes function
which um
which is an or of a bunch of ends and
each end is called a tribe
um
and
this function outputs one
if and only
if at least one tribe
is unanimous or all the bits in a
particular tri bar are all one
and sort of famous extreme of boolean
function
um
and
each influence of and the influence of
each coordinate on the tribes function
is is log n over n and the analogous
symmetric convex body here is um is the
solid cube so
it's the set of points um
it's it's a set of points uh
for which
uh each coordinate is uh at most
root log n up to um
at most root log and an absolute value
and it turns out that the influence of
each coordinate direction of um
of the solid cube is
uh on the order of log n over n
so so far it seems like um this notion
of convex influences
convex influence passes some really
really elementary sanity checks um
but um this this this correspondence
seems to extend um
extend deeper
in particular we are
we are able to obtain analog analogs of
some signature results from boolean
function analysis for this new notion of
symmetric convex sets and convex
influence um for some other common sense
in particular we obtain um
you know an analog the poincare
inequality the kkl inequality
um
a sharp threshold result along the lines
of figure
um
a robust density increment result along
the lines of what donald and we're
obtained a few years ago and a weak
feed good hyundai theory was sort of a
consequence of free goods and bathroom
and i just want to emphasize that the
the proof techniques that we use here
are are completely different from um
the techniques used to prove
the
the corresponding statements over the
boolean hypercube
and i'm going to spend the next few
minutes sort of briefly and at a very
high level sketching the proof of the
kkl analog
so just remind everyone the kkl theorem
of the boolean
hypercube says that if a function has
if if each coordinate has very small
influence on a function
or more concretely if the influence of
each coordinate um
on this function f is at most epsilon
then the total influence is at least log
one over epsilon times the variance of
the function so in other words if all
the influences are small
then the total influence is still
reasonably large
and this is sort of a
celebrated well-known result um
and it sort of sharpens the poincare
inequality
to for boolean functions this inequality
is also tight and it's typed for the
tribes function which we saw a few
slides ago and its proof relies on hyper
contractivity
and the analogous statement
um for symmetric convex sets turns out
to be pretty much what you would expect
um
so if k is symmetric convex set for
which um the influence of any direction
on this set is at most epsilon
and we've got this additional condition
that that the variance of the set case
at least epsilon
then the total convex influence of the
set k is at least
the variance of
the set
k times the square root of log
of the variance of the sub divided by
epsilon so we've got this additional
square root factor as opposed to the
boolean kkl theorem
um
and
i'm going to sketch the proof
at a very very high level again just to
emphasize the fact that
the techniques used to prove these
statements for
convex influences um
are are very different from the
techniques used to prove the
the analogous statements for
boolean functions although the statement
sort of looked the same
um in particular the the proof of this
kkl theorem for symmetric convex sets
avoids the use of use of
hypercontractivity or the log super
level equality
so
um
we start off with uh the dilation
characterization of total influence
which
again just remind everyone tells you how
quickly the set grows
um or how quickly the gaussian margin
set grows under dilations
and we sort of we we then appeal to the
gaussian isoparametric inequality
to
conclude that um the
total influence is at least the variance
times the in radius of the set
um
and we we sort of crucially use
convexity and that just and the
hyperplane separation theorem here and
then we sort of focus on this in radius
um quantity
and rely on a on a brass camp leave
inequality due to impala um a breast
cancer type inequality due to the impala
to conclude that uh
the in radius is at least square root of
the variance divided by epsilon and
putting these two things together um
gives you that the total influences
is uh is at least
variance times square root log variance
of epsilon
and
as i just mentioned this is sort of
quadratically weaker
than the
kkl for boolean functions and a natural
next direction would be to um
obtain a stronger kkl and there's many
other directions um that you could take
this notion of convex influences in in
particular it's natural to hope for a
feedback
analog for for convex influences um
it's also
it'd be
very interesting to sort of think about
algorithmic applications of this new
notion of convex influence
um and another sort of very interesting
question would be to obtain a robust
version of um one of our earlier sanity
checks for convex influence so if you
remember we showed that if
a direction has convex influence zero
then the set is a cylinder along that
direction up to measure zero
um
and a robust version of the statement
would be something along the lines of
uh something along the lines is
following if if if a direction has very
small influence then is the set close in
some sense to
a cylinder along that direction
so just to recap we've got this new and
exciting notion of convex influence
for
symmetric convex sets of a gaussian
space
and
we are able to obtain
analogs of some signature results or
from boolean function analysis for this
new notion of influence and it seems
like there's a lot of exciting new
things to pursue here